do you remember your first kiss
or that time you burnt the roof of your
mouth on a hot slice of pizza
what about playing tag or duckduckgoose
as a child
these are all instances where we're
using touch to understand something
and it's the basis of haptic design
haptic means of or relating to the sense
of touch and we've all been using that
our entire lives
i was working on my computer with my
friend
seeing me hunched over typing walked
over behind me she put her left thumb
into the left side of my lower back
while reaching her right index finger
around to the front of my right shoulder
instinctively i sat up straight
in one quick and gentle gesture she had
communicated how to improve my posture
the paper i was working on at that very
moment centered around developing new
ways to teach movement using technology
i wanted to create a suit that could
teach a person kung fu
but i had no idea how to communicate
movement without an instructor being in
the room
and in that moment it became crystal
clear
touch
if i have vibrating motors where she had
placed each of her fingers
paired with motion capture data of my
current and optimal posture
i could simulate the entire experience
without an instructor needing to be in
the room
but there was still one important part
of the puzzle that was missing
if i want you to raise your wrist two
inches off of your lap using vibration
how do i tell you to do
that do i put a motor at the top of your
wrist so you know to lift up
or do i put one at the bottom of your
wrist so it feels like you're being
pushed up
there were no readily available answers
because there was no commonly agreed
upon haptic language to communicate
information with so my co-founders and i
set out to create that language
and the first device we built
was not a kung fu suit
but in a way it was even more impressive
because of its simplicity and usefulness
we started with the use case of
navigation
which is a simplified form of movement
we then created wayband
a wrist wearable device that could
orient a user to water destination using
vibrating cues
we would ask people to spin around
and to stop in a way that they felt was
the right way to go
and formally we tried to split hundreds
of people and most could figure it out
within about 15 seconds
it was that intuitive
initially we were just trying to get
people out of their phones and back into
the real world
but the more we experimented the more we
realized that those who stood the
benefit most from our work
were people who had little or no sight
when we first approached a blind
organization they told us
don't build a blind device
build the device that everyone can use
but that's optimized for the blind
experience
we created our company whereworks with
three guiding principles
make cool stuff
create the greatest impact we can in our
lifetimes
and reimagine an entire world designed
for touch
and on november 5th 2017
wayband helped the person who was blind
run the first 15 miles of the new york
city marathon without any sighted
assistance
[Applause]
it didn't get them through the entire
race due to the heavy rain but that
didn't matter
we had proved the point
that it was possible to navigate a
complex route using only touch
so why touch
the skin has an innate sensitivity akin
to the eye's ability to recognize
millions of colors or the ears ability
to recognize complex pitch and tone yes
a communications channel it's been
largely relegated to morse code like
cell phone notifications
if you were to suddenly receive a kiss
or a punch
your reaction would be instinctive and
immediate
meanwhile your brain would be playing
catch up on the back end and understand
the details of what just occurred
and compared to instincts conscious
thought is pretty slow
but it's a lightning bolt compared to
the snail's pace of language acquisition
i spent a considerable amount of time
learning spanish
japanese
german and currently swedish with
varying degrees of failure
[Laughter]
but within those failures where kernels
of how different languages are organized
that gave our team insight into how to
use the linguistic order of
well-established languages
as inspiration for an entirely new
haptic language one based purely on
touch
it also showed us when using language
mechanics wasn't the best way to deliver
information
in the same way a smile was a smile
across every culture
what if there was some underlying
mechanism of touch that transcended
linguistic and cultural boundaries
a universal language of sort
you see i could give you buzz buzz buzz
buzz buzz
and you would eventually learn that that
particular vibration means stop
but as haptic designers we challenged
ourselves
what would it be like to design stop
well based on context most of us have
the experience of being in a vehicle and
having that vehicle stop suddenly along
with our body's reaction to it
so if i wanted you to stop i could send
you a vibration pattern sure or
i could design a haptic experience that
just made stopping
feel like it was the right thing to do
and that takes more than an arbitrary
assignment of haptic cues to meanings
it takes a deep empathy
it also takes the ability to distill
human experience into meaningful
insights
and then into haptic gestures and
products
haptic design is going to expand the
human ability to sense and respond to
our environment both physical and
virtual there's a new frontier
touch
and it has the power to change how we
all see the world around us
thank you
you